hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're gonna discuss the truth about red
meat now before we start I do know that
this is very controversial subject and a
lot of people are very passionate about
you know animals being killed in that
but I want to talk about just about the
health benefits about actual red meat
and really kind of dig deep in what the
studies say there's first of all you
have to realize that there are multiple
studies that disagree with red meat
being the source of cancer okay however
the study called the nurse health study
and I'll put the link down below if you
actually read it states that it
increases your risk by 13% of dying of
all illnesses or diseases okay so it
does increase your risk so and they said
you need to switch to chicken whole
grains okay but let's take a look at
what kind of study they actually did to
confirm that first of all it wasn't an
experimental City it was an
observational study based on a
questionnaire that was given out every
two years from 1980 to 2006 now I will
guarantee there's when you do a
questionnaire for a study it's not a
controlled study there are so many
variables you can't isolate these
variables like other things that people
aid if they're smoker or whatnot so it
leaves the things up to a lot of biases
and it's very very weak but here's an
interesting thing they always used the
word risk okay what is risk me why don't
they just say rate of getting cancer or
dying
well because risk has a different term
legally it actually is more open it
doesn't necessarily mean you have a 13%
rate of getting of dying so it's kind of
a big variable there now the other thing
is they did not identify if it was
grass-fed beef was it processed beef was
it organic
whether that McDonald's they didn't
measure that data okay so the question
is what are the real statistics from
Studies on processed meat
okay process red meat you know it's
classified as a class 1 carcinogen at
the same level of smoke
King right so of course people are
freaking out about it but take a look at
like bowel cancer
they found that three more incidents of
bowel cancer occur per a hundred
thousand people okay
hundred thousand cases that's one in
thirty three thousand cases so they have
three more incidents of bowel cancer
well cancer I mean smoking increases
your chance by 20 X 20 times more so
that's like you can't compare those two
it's not really a class 1 carcinogen
it's now what I want to talk about is I
do not believe that there's any risk or
any studies that show that consuming
grass-fed quality beef will increase
your risk of dying at all or any
diseases okay now the benefit of red
meat and by the way I consume a lot of
red meat I don't do a lot per sitting
I'll do a small amount maybe 3 or 4
ounces but I do my body feels great on
really good red meat the kind of the red
meat that I buy I don't buy the 90
percent lean I buy the 85 percent
because that lean stuff I just it's
harder to digest and when it has fat in
it so that's just a side note but red
meat has more observable vitamin D than
milk ok it has more b12 b1 b2 b3 b6 b5
it has tons of observable iron it has
healthy collagen it has a good amount of
potassium believe it or not it has zinc
magnesium copper phosphates and it's
loaded with omega-3 in fact it has five
times more omega-3 grass-fed beef has 5
times more Omega 3 than grain fed beef
and the problem with grain fed is not
only sometimes you involve hormones but
you involve the genetically modified GMO
soy and corn in the feed so that's
another big problem that they would I
would love for them to do a study on
that so when you do research I think the
problem with
research is that you're gonna actually
try that first have a theory and then
you're going to come find research to
back it up and that's how people
approach it they have this thing that's
fixed idea in mind and now I'm going to
find research to back up my theory and
then so I can prove my theory rather
than do an evaluation on the data and
see where it ends up it's a better
viewpoint okay so that's my two cents on
meat and thanks for watching
put your comments below hey guys thank
you so much for watching please click
the subscribe button and I will see you
in the next video